[Music]
welcome to a special episode of whatsa
Prof hello
Walter hello Scotty
hello hello Scotty
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so we've got an interesting setup
here
tonight and uh before we begin we ask to
we have to ask the Lord for a blessing
for this
evening our heavenly
father thank you very much for this
opportunity
we have a
foraste of what it would be like when
you come to fetch us and we consider
that great
table so we ask now that you bless our
discussion Enlighten the minds of of all
of us
here and let the Holy Spirit be present
along with the angels please in Jesus
name
amen
amen right we're going to talk tonight
about him who thinks he
stands let him take heed lest he
falls and we were sitting here today and
we had prepared this uh WhatsApp prop
series
and I was listening or we were listening
to Scotti
seminar and you know that he's an expert
on
media and he was talking about
influences how to influence people's
minds to do something that they wouldn't
normally
do
and uh as I was listening I was thinking
you know what this is exactly what every
single one of us is going to have to
[Music]
face because very soon every single one
of us present in this Hall
and throughout the world that knows the
truth is going to be placed under
pressure
mhm so I said to Martin let's ask Scot
will come and help
[Music]
us so I'm very grateful that you said
yes I'm so happy you're here this is
great I get a front row seat to this
amazing
show I love the work that you guys
do I think it helps us keep our eyes on
the current
[Music]
present and has one arm linking back to
Bible
truth
and how it's relevant for us
today so I'm I'm
excited thank you thank you very
much cool and I must just also say we
also enjoy your show little light
Studio little light studos praise
God so let's jump right into
it I don't know whether you will
remember this picture we had it in a
previous WhatsApp Prof it's a a cover of
The
[Music]
Economist and it's almost like
predictive programming isn't it well it
came out what is the picture
he The Economist economus and it's
and important to to realize because when
we look at some of the interesting top
part of it it's
predictive if you look at the top there
you will
see that there are an explosions going
on and there's a war and it's between
Hamas and
Israel
Israel and at the top the red there
you'll see they're coming in on hang
gliders motorized hang
gliders not only that you have the
entertainment world in the frontier we
spoke about this one in a previous one
with with Simon keeping the world
occupied with their famous
[Music]
program with America's Got Talent Show
you
know and you have the devil there
controlling the climate control
issue you have political leaders you
have economic collapse you have
everything in this
picture this is a whole plan for all the
influence that they want to put out
there on the
world
so Scotty you were
saying that uh you were wondering when
the economic collapse is going to come
right
okay you know the devil is only
counterfeiting the things of
God and just like God tells everybody
what's going to happen before it
happens
this is his way of telling people what
he thinks is going to
happen I will always go as far as to say
what he's planning not even
thinking but I want to tell all of you
we have a more sure word of pray
prophecy
amen why we want to talk about
this is because if they are planning all
of these things and to bring the world
into a unified pattern of
thinking if you are forew warn you are
for
armed correct yeah so if you know that
the thief is coming you can prepare for
it so we have a predictive programming
which is called
prophecy
so let's talk about a few issues that
the world is being programmed
with we are being told that there is a
tremendous climate crisis in the
world and from all the evidence I
believe that this is a ru
to prepare the world for Sunday
legislation and they don't care what
they do to the economy in fact they want
to do it to the
economy so let's take away all fossil
fuels
[Music]
and let's see if we can dump the Nations
into a total
chaos but it's always interesting to see
who's the main spokesperson behind it
all
and I'm sure you all know because his
pictures on on the
screen and I don't want you to be
distracted and think that the problem is
going to come from
elsewhere you are even so fortunate that
you know who his main agents
are
[Music]
and the Beast out of the earth is in
cohoots with the Beast that came out of
the
sea so I suggest you keep a half eye on
them and one and a half eyes on
Jesus it always has to be in the
majority of your
mind and that's just an
intro here's another slide Martin run us
through there it's just to
show no this is just to show that I know
we've showed it before the problem with
this whole climate change thing is
that the whole time we've heard we must
follow the
science but then if you look at what the
model the models tell
you against what the the real
life it's totally different for instance
on
this it they always say that for more
than 100 years there's already been heat
waves it's not climate change that's
causing the heat
waves in fact it was four times higher
in the 1930s than now but everywhere
around on the news you hear that this is
the worse it's ever
been so is this predict trying to steer
your thoughts into a re um in a
direction without you actually doing
investigation if it's actually
so
and if you repeat something over and
over eventually it gets lodged into your
mind and even if you are against it you
can be caught running with
it Scotty you spoke about Tyler Swift
today that
she's a major
influencer but she can just be the
trigger and it sets off a domino effect
can you just expand on
that so they were taking a look at the
reason why Taylor Swift is dating a
football
[Music]
star and when she goes to the football
games
immediately when they show her
[Music]
image they have a spike of 400%
increase in people buying the jersey of
her
[Music]
boyfriend and so they were looking at
that influence of simply just seeing
somebody
well how many of the actors Sports
celebrities and all of them believe CH
chains is a
reality I think they've proven that
people follow people that's the
thing there's a reason why you see a lot
of celebrities talking on these
issues ex presidents talking on these
issues and we've become surface
readers we're not actually digging into
the deep
research so if we're only reading the
headlines how is that really truly
impacting what we actually believe about
it
well that brings us back
to how informed are we we think that we
will stand in what is about to
come in many studies of social
conformity
they've studied this at length with
human
nature and the one thing that they've
proven over and over
again we don't like to be the one
person that is sticking out like a sore
thumb and going against the
flow it's easier to go along with the
majority now God's faithful people
throughout the
ages were there ever a
majority no and even though we have so
many people here this
evening in the world you are a
minority
and very soon you're going to become a
very very prominent
minority and if you don't have an
anchor the tsunami that is coming is
going to sweep you and me and everyone
else
away you go back in history you read in
the Bible that whatever happened to the
Israelites these things were there as an
example and they were written for our
admonition on whom the ends of the world
are
come and I want you to write this into
your Minds tonight
wherefore let him that thinketh he
standeth take heed lest you
fall we have to all take heat of
that nobody is
excluded New York was already a loser
State I would never invest in New York
now and I'm not the only person saying
that New York has become a legal Banana
Republic truckers for Trump is is
trending right now heard that there were
going to be 700,000 truck drivers
protesting well some of President
Trump's supporters are pushing back
against what they see as an unfair
justice system threatening a boycott
that could have a major impact on the
country's largest city some truck
drivers say they're planning on refusing
shipments to and from New York City some
of these truckers saying you know what
we we're not going into New York because
of what happened to Donald Trump if I'm
just anybody living in New York and I
see see that headline and you hear what
that that woman said off the top of the
show uh should they be
concerned I've been on the radio talking
talking to drivers for about the last
hour hour 15
minutes and uh I talked to at least 10
drivers going the other way I'm heading
down from sou
Wisconsin and uh they're going to start
refusing loads in New York City starting
not Monday yeah the man calls himself
Chicago Ray and as of last night his
post on X formerly Twitter had garnered
more than 6 million views and 60,000
likes former president Trump also caught
win of what Chicago Ray is doing and
reposted Ray's video on his platform Tru
social thank you okay so maybe just
explain the bottom bottom line is you
all you all aware of what Isen happening
in in New York with the Trump case and
the tremendous fine that he got for
whatever they claimed he
did is making people take a stand for a
particular
position
and one trucker said I'm not going to
take anything more to New York and I
challenge all the others to do the
same because they don't agree with what
the judge did to
Trump and then he backtracked and said
now I don't want to be involved I didn't
want to cause any
problem but it was too late because
thousands of others had already jumped
on the
bandwagon so Scotty there was an
influencer and even though he
backtracked it was too
late because just by putting the thought
into the public
mind the consequences will be seen in
the near
future imagine if that person stood for
something good and
true what if that was in the front page
of the
[Music]
news but you know it's a scary
part they believe it is good and
true and they
actually there is a spiritual side to
this even if we don't know it but that
is the conservative side so they will
say it's for
God this is true in the end people will
think they're serving
God seeking out those that truly follow
God may I do a little experiment with
all of
you
just by a show of
[Music]
hands could you tell me who of you think
that the sentence that the judge gave to
Trump was
unfair how many of you think it was
unfair
there are quite a number of hands that
are going up that
say now just the fact that you think
that it's unfair whether it is or not is
now
Irrelevant in a sense puts your sympathy
on his
side
and if your sympathy is on his side
could he then become an influencer in
terms of other
things what do you think
Martin we can ask the same question
about the interview that taka Carlson
had with
Putin all of a sudden a lot of people
people have a lot of respect for Tucker
Carlson especially when you're
conservative so whether you are uh you
like Putin or not it already gives you
okay maybe I should listen to what he
said God people must keep their eyes
focused upon the truth and its unfolding
in this
time they must never allow themselves to
be dragged into a
situation where they become part of a
group
process
because Scot you showed that when the
group was
there the people wouldn't leave the
Fire Group pressure is
enormous because we don't want to be the
single one causing a
problem to the point that people would
be willing to lose their
life in a dangerous
situation now what if you change that
word life to eternal
life do you realize in what
serious trouble we would be if we
develop an identity with any philosophy
of the world other than God's
philosophy now here's the next slide and
it comes from the journal Politico
okay
political and in case you think we're
not doing anything look at the date it's
the 20th of the 2nd
20124 Trump allies prepared to infuse
Christian nationalism in second
Administration
so they're talking about this
influential Think Tank close to Donald
Trump that is planning to
infuse Christian nationalism into the
administration from day
[Music]
one
let me make it quite clear whether Trump
wins or not is not relevant because the
devil can use either side to bring about
his
agenda and we all know that their
documents that they have set up tell us
that from
2025 from day one they want to implement
this
agenda and we all also
know that the Sabbath issue is very
prominent in that
document
that's the main thing we must always
remember what is Satan's main
focus Right Through the Ages it's an
attack on the
Sabbath and all of this you can see we
were talking about it
earlier is moving it back to
religion
so like you mentioned in the the project
document it's again about the
Sabbath and why is it against the
Sabbath because the Sabbath is the
Commandment that confirms the authority
of
God and the devil rejects the authority
God so has placed another agent on this
Earth and he's behind it because
Revelation tells us
that and in order to elevate another
Authority he has to get rid of the
Sabbath so the world is prepared for
this
and we will have to make
choices this is the trucker that said he
started the whole thing but he
backtracks I may have a question
here that's why the title is be careful
you think you stand L you fall will we
backtrack
when things got start getting
tough when things start getting
tough if you want to make a decision to
stand for truth and
righteousness and you must make that
decision
now and you must become grounded in in
that
decision you must become so settled in
that truth that you cannot be
moved and that is the definition of
being
sealed because to be sealed is to be so
settled in the truth that you cannot be
moved so make the decision
now with any discipline that you have in
life whether you want to play the piano
or or play a
sport they will practice that activity
over and over and over
again so that it becomes a natural
instinct without even thinking about
it we have little moments in our life
today for you to stand for
truth call it practice if you
will and if you practice that
enough when the moment really
matters
you've already trained yourself to make
the right
decision there's a reason
why Daniel starts out with the food
issue that's a tiny little bit of an
opportunity every single day you
get to choose what you put in your mouth
because someday your choice may come
into
play just wanted to say that test
already started in Eden actually
also we continue to see misinformation
on social media and in mainstream media
about the pandemic Accord that countries
are now negotiating the claim that the
Accord will seed power to who is quite
simply false it's fake news countries
will decide what the Accord says and
countries alone and countries will
implement the Accord in line with their
own National laws no country will seed
any sovereignity to who those were
clearly lies and of course his saying
that into a camera is supposed to
convince you you know nobody could
possibly lie so directly so there must
be some truth in what he's saying which
is of course nonsense and anybody who
goes back through uh Matt Ora's
compendium of various things that people
have said into cameras over the course
of Co that they then swear they didn't
say you know months later um knows that
these folks are very comfortable at
saying totally false things into a
camera doesn't cause them to to think
twice or sweat or
anything run us through that okay so I
don't know if you guys could hear very
clearly
but I'm sure that you could hear but
unfortunately we have to translate it
but basically what he said was
everything that Ted said
there was a
lie and that if you think those people
looking into a camera and
talking are incapable of lying to
you you can just look back at what
happened during the
pandemic and then you'll understand that
if you look at the document that he's
speaking about is completely
lying
so the bottom line again is when you see
something in the
news you have to pour it through the
filter and the filter is the sure word
of
Prophecy you have to ask yourself the
question are they trying to force my
conscience to contradict
itself and if the answer to that is yes
you must distance yourself from it
immediately because God will never coers
your conscience
now you remember during the crisis that
we
had during all the
lockdowns lock it was claimed by foui
that social distancing was extremely
important
in fact he claimed right before the
select subc committies of the house that
6 fet apart was what was what should be
done
in okay he actually said this not
following the science if you don't do it
yes you must follow the science
therefore you must have social
distancing but then it was stated there
quite bluntly that there is no
scientific data to support
that so the scientific data came
straight out of this man 's
head and he backtracked on it
okay but it is very likely that when the
next one which is called X
strikes that all those same measures
will be introduced
again
now I want to ask you a
question in the last crisis that we that
we experienced in this
world during that
crisis did people make a
choice were many convinced by what the
media was
saying there were experts in a
particular direction that got a lot of
media
coverage and there were thousands that
got either no media coverage or negative
media
[Music]
coverage and the whole world ran after
the
media did the churches run after the
media how many of the churches ran with
the
media was it that big word
all so is it possible that you can run
with an ideology and an idea even if it
is contrary to your choice and
conscience
what do you
think it's amazing that more people did
not question the science of
course I appreciated what you said last
night question the
science now I'm not a
scientist but is that in the scientific
Community what you would do is keep
asking questions till you find out the
truth in the scientific world we have
something which is called peer
review in other words you publish your
data with all the necessary criteria of
your experiment mental
procedure and then you put it out to
peer review in other words you send it
to prominent people working in the same
field to critically assess the
scientific method
and only if it passes that test will it
be
published but something else has come
into science and that is follow the
money
trial and it's very interesting what
happens when you follow the money
Tri the money track the money
Tri it's very interesting what
happens because if a big company
finances your
research then they want the answers that
they
want and you can experiment until you
get them
and now it's very interesting that some
of the editors of the top scientific
journals in the world
today as recently as the last few
weeks have distanced themselves from
their journals because they say it's no
longer true science it's
propaganda now brothers and
sisters are you all scientists that
conver the
science
definitely
not but you all have common
sense and you're all sitting here
because you made a
choice and you made that choice based on
your reasoning
capacity so if you're going to follow
all the science and even some of the
scien scientists are distancing
themselves from the
science then make very sure that you
make your decisions based on your Solid
Rock
philosophy
now it's very easy to go and uh become
very vociferous and angry let's say
against the
pope and then if you get a little bit of
pressure you might just backtrack very
quickly
you all know what happened to your
neighboring
country so let's look at
it a photo op that seemed impossible
just two months ago Argentina's Pope
Francis greeting ultraconservative
president cavier m in the Vatican
followed by an emotional
embrace
that's because few politicians anywhere
have insulted the pope like mle who
during his campaign called the pontiff a
defender of bloodthirsty dictators and a
communist that imbecile in Rome who
defends social justice should be
informed that it goes against the Ten
Commandments social justice is a capital
sin and
aberration but now the president has
changed his tune in a 70-minute meeting
in the Vatican melay is reported to have
apologized to the pope for his
statements the pope then brushed them
off as quote errors of
Youth so Martin what happened
there okay don't know if you guys heard
it so mle in his whole campaign and also
in his interview with tu
cson and even on that interview in the
news he called the pope an
imbecile and then afterward he
apologized and went and kissed the
pope so he backtracked 180 very quickly
again it just goes to show you beer
pressure simp
fear for his life
maybe perhaps it was all an act perhaps
they are
actors but did his actions have other
people get
reaction and I was just thinking you
were mentioning
earlier that it's sad that all churches
were involved so they were scared to
stand alone like the people in that fire
building in the the fire video that he
showed
I believe we've been blessed with so
much beautiful truth in our
church we have a very unique
perspective that God is allowed us to
understand what's going on behind the
scene and I believe that we missed a
great
opportunity T not share with the world
what we
know because we were fearful of what
they would think of
us so will we make the same mistake as
we just saw in this
video or will we
stand the spirit of Prophecy tells us
that a greater number than we now
expect will leave our ranks and walk
with us no
more are you rooted in the
truth do you know who the little horn
power
is do you really believe that the papacy
is the first Beast of Revelation chap
13 so when they ask you to come and bow
down like the president
did are you going to tie your
shoelaces
I wear a shoe without the Shoe La so
that I'm not tempted to do
that maybe you must just explain what it
means to TI what what you talking about
well if you tie your shoeless you have
to bend down to tie it don't
you now did Daniel's three friends bow
down to sh tie their
shoelaces but you were speaking about
that and there were a few hundred Exiles
with him and only three didn't tie their
shoelaces only three did not bow down to
the
[Music]
image
brothers and sisters
everything is on the
table if Christian nationalism becomes a
norm in the United States of America the
image of the Beast will have formed
completely
does that mean for every one of
us doesn't it mean we must be
prepared and is this propaganda going to
move
us what does it say in Daniel 3:
15 it
says now if you be ready that at what
time you hear the sound of the Cornet
the
fluid so you mentioned all the musical
instruments that's
great fall down and wor
ship is music going to play a large role
in preparing a people to bow down to the
image all kinds of
music in that same
hour when they refuse they were thrown
into the fiery
furnace now we were talking about Mega
Stars weren't we Scotty
mhm are they going to be used to
influence a
mindset have you noticed how many
superstars are coming out Christian
m
they're going to
church they are doing religious
things people you wouldn't even expect
at all to have any connection to
God so on the
surface we think this might be a good
thing but if we
know that the end will be of a relig I
order then we need to understand what
prophecy
says how many of us could actually tell
our neighbors right
now all about
prophecy could you give a prophecy
seminar to your
neighbor if you can't say
yes look into it and study
it I think it's
amazing that shadra M and
even when they were asked we'll give
you another
chance they already made the
decision they had the time to
backtrack and do a 180° turn around like
all the people that we've seen in the
slides before
now and I love it they said you don't
even need to give us a second chance
King even if God doesn't save
us it won't change my
decision and I think that we are called
to have that same mindset
brothers and
sisters where did their decision making
start was it here at the fiery furnace
or was it
earlier what was the first decision they
had to
make that put them at the pain of death
even in that
time to counteract the King's Command
was a very dangerous thing to
do it started with a decision on
diet and we as a people have not taken
this issue seriously enough
it started with the issue of
diet but that's why I'm interested that
this camp meeting has a big portion on
on
[Applause]
health you think we're just trying to be
evil influence or do you think maybe God
is
pleading with everyone please if you do
not stand on this issue how are you
going to stand on that
issue I know you're on that
page
[Music]
did you get any opposition from family
and friends when you switched your
lifestyle I maybe forgot to put that
into the
testimony when we got into the church I
met a lot of
friends but then when we accepted the
health me actually lost it lot as
well and why is
that because unfortunately the health
message doesn't seem to be as
influential as the negative
things did you have the thought though
when you saw what the world went through
in
Ah that's why God told this
church and gave us lots of years to
practice because
maybe some
point we're going to deal with something
with our health
God knew it for
sure and the sad thing
is there was maybe a lot of those that
did not prepare like Daniel and that was
a test for the first test that was
almost like the first approach of the
Roman army for the destruction of
Jerusalem
and now they've pulled back but they
will come
again but they're coming
again do we do we have a right arm to
the third Angel's
message do you think the devil has a
counterfeit to the right arm of his
message so will the mark of the beast
have a right
arm the answer is
yes if if the truth has a right arm then
the counterfeit has a right
arm what is his
called it's called
phia
phia and we heard today in a health
seminar that that is a in to
Witchcraft it's a very serious
allegation but if it's very cleverly
packed and
uh
influenced it can sway the majority
[Music]
mhm all right let me ask a counter
question how many people in the
world embrace the natural
approach to the health
issue very few and the min
Focus so again it is a
minority brothers and sisters do you
want to be part of the
minority if it's based on the word I
minority so they stood no matter what
the pressure was no matter what the
emotional issue
was they used music they used
propaganda they swept up the
emotions and most of the Israelites
bowed down to the
image
please don't let it happen to
you here's a quote from the great
controversy the spokesman of the diet
this was in Martin Luther's time said
angry you have not answered the question
put to you you are required to give a
clear and precise answer will you or
will you not
retract the reformer answered I cannot
submit my
faith either to the pope or the
[Music]
counil fair because it is clear as day
that they have frequently heard and
contradicted each
other has the so-called science
other the answer is yes for sure we're
living in the same situation there's
nothing new Under the Sun
so unless I am convinced by the
testimony of scripture or by the
clearest
reasoning unless I am persuaded by means
of the passages I have quoted and unless
they thus render my conscience Bound by
the word of God I cannot and will not
retract
for it is unsafe for a Christian to
speak against his
conscience here I stand I can do no
other make God help me
amen
when those
five no let's make it 10 when those 10
virgins woke
up and five didn't have enough
[Applause]
oil they were not bad people they were
virgins they were in the church they
were part of the
Bride
and they went to go and buy
[Applause]
oil and then they ran to the
feast and the door was
closed brothers and
sisters it was too
late
they tried to get the oil they tried to
listen to what the Holy Spirit had been
pleading with them for
years when the crisis that came they
said okay Lord help us help us to get
this thing right
now
but they all lost eternal life all five
of them they didn't get
in this is a major major
problem so when should we get enough
oil and if oil is the holy spirit
oil then Acts chapter 5 tells me it's
given to them that obey
him so what was the
problem they knew the truth but they
didn't obey
it and it's too late to change your
character in a second you have to work
at it
now would you agree
[Music]
if you don't do it
now be careful L you think you stand and
you fall that's the whole where it comes
back
to if we truly are in a Leia
State and we think I'm
fine I don't need
this I don't need the the
[Music]
truth I know what's
true the Bible tells us that we need to
buy buy that eyes so that we can
see what's
coming we should be praying
that God gives us his
glasses that he we give his
understanding and I believe that he will
not ignore
us for
sure I
believe and I'm telling you this in all
earnestness that we don't have much
time if we don't act now we won't have
enough
oil we heard today in many talks
creating me a clean heart oh
Lord search me whether there's any
wicked thing in
me wash me with his
so that I may be whiter than
[Music]
snow signs of the
times signs of the times the greatest
want of this
age
so the greatest want of this
age and when you read Men read women
because they are
one men who will not be bought or sold
men who are true and honest in their
inmost soul men who will not fear to
call Sin By Its Right
name and to condemn
it now listen
carefully in themselves or in
others
man whose conscience is as true to duty
as the needle to the PO men who will
stand for the right of the heavens
fall this camp meeting might be the last
call
and therefore my appeal would
be do what David
did search me oh
Lord if there's something I have known
and have
neglected help me to make it right
now help me to come into harmony with
your
will and forgive my
stubbornness because the time is at
hand have you got any closing Arguments
for the people
I'll just say
that we've got that choice still to
make make it right
now and be that
influence for
positive to other
people
get involved with sharing your
faith practice with sharing with those
around
you because I
believe like salt of the
earth nobody eats a plate of
salt but if that salt is put on the
food can greatly enhance the
food we are the salt of the
earth and when that time
comes when the world will be confused on
many of these
issues if you've studied and you
know and are able to
explain why these things are
happening and then tell them to
subscribe to their Channel on
YouTube and learn about what is
happening
today be
encouraged we're going home soon
amen let's
pray our loving Heavenly
Father we have exceeded the Israelites
of
old we have been worse than
them we have been just as stiff
necked as they
were and Lord change our
hearts because the truth is
beautiful the devil's counterfeit only
leads to
death if we embrace the truth the truth
will set us
free there is no happier person on this
planet Lord than he that is steeped in
your
will
[Music]
because your will is life and happiness
and
peace great peace have they who love thy
law that means even in the middle of a
storm they will have
peace Lord we've been told the storm is
coming Relentless in its Fury
help us to stand that the heavens
fall is my prayer on behalf of all your
people and may their witness shake the
world and pluck many brands from the
fire before it is too
late is my prayer in jesus' name
amen
[Music]